a march in silence to mourn the death of
a french schoolteacher stabbed and
decapitated in broad daylight
in a suburb of paris yet political
reaction to the murder of history
teacher samuel patty
is anything but quiet
[Music]
to the sound of the national anthem
members of the french parliament
gathered
then a minute silence afterwards
came this proclamation
we are united standing and determined to
fight the instigator of this murder
because in mr samuel patti lies the
france that is republican and humanist
that was cravenly and atrociously
attacked
emmanuel macron the french president has
ordered a crackdown
on muslim organizations
as of tomorrow at the cabinet meeting we
will dissolve the sheikah soon
collective
directly implicated in the attack more
decisions against associations and
groups of individuals will follow in the
coming days and weeks
our determination is complete the acts
will happen
the republic needs them here worshippers
at a mosque that's been closed down by
the interior minister
who claims its leaders shared an online
video
saying samuel patti should be
intimidated
he says they also shared the address of
his
from the moment someone relays a video
you should chase him not the mosque not
a whole community
protest against what the government has
described as muslim extremism
followed patti's death
he had been killed by an
eighteen-year-old of chechen origin
who was shot dead by police
[Applause]
earlier this month muslim parents
objected after the teacher had shown
cartoons of the prophet muhammad
in a lesson about freedom of expression
the images were first shown by the
satirical magazine
charlie hebdo and that led to a wave of
attacks in 2015.
what's happening in paris right now is
causing more divisiveness
along with fears that what political
leaders call a
zero tolerance to islamic extremism will
escalate
into more violence in both communities
andrew simmons al jazeera